[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we have a new
addition
h portico security specializing cash
trucks across la do you have any idea
how dangerous this job can be
somehow yeah we ain't the predators
we're the prey
you ready ready
this is your temporary sidearm why
aren't you fully putting pistols in the
machine guys
do you have a problem i don't know do i
it's a 10 grand drop you should have
been back five minutes ago
they're serious leave this to me
get in the truck next time sorry pal
it doesn't feel right
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop but if he's not a cop
what is he
a while back we lost two cars civilian
too
there was an investigation we still
haven't found a scum who did it
you're in an accident you're not my son
he didn't make it i need to not kill my
son
the tree has been shook and it's been
shook hard
we've scorched the earth
you started by certainly do anything
what i'm hearing
is you think you've done everything
[Music]
i can see it's gonna be a long night
it's gotta be an inside job can do it in
two weeks
you know what i wish you could do in 20
years
when i do bury grudge
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind hopefully harley's still
alive
no funny business these are dangerous
people
team two is clear to go fire uh three
two what are you guys doing what
you were here to save you you were gonna
save me it was a really good plan too
i can go back inside and you can still
do it that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull you can do
the job for free this is the famous
suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all going to die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early although
that isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan uh how much listen up
you're the leader you're supposed to be
decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
if this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans well that's why mad men do
what they do
well that's kind of our thing
[Music]
don't you worry i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
like angels are splooting all over us
[Music]
why'd they put you in a fire tower
[Music]
well i'm just lucky i guess
i read the wind wrong
[Music]
i should have gone to them
[Music]
then you've been dead too
that's our job
[Music]
hey stop i'm not going to hurt you i
want to see where the blood's coming
from it's not my blood
you in trouble
anyone else in trouble
my dad said if anything happened i
should find someone i could trust
are you someone i can trust
we promise absolutes
act accordingly
did you see their faces
cut you down
give them something else to worry about
that eats everything in its path
you really want to die for this kid
take a deep breath
hold it
lay back
what happens next
looking right in the eyes
basketball camp is next weekend you got
amazing potential on the court
and i can help you get there that's not
what i want dad
you never let me do what i want to do
you never let me just
do me hold up wrong floor
that will smith i gotta deal with this
what in the matrix hello
[Music]
welcome king james i am the king of this
domain
this is the server what'd you do to my
son where's dom
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball
pete send this clown to the rejects
what is this
i'm a cartoon what's up doc
i need to assemble an elite team to help
get my son back i know what you're
looking for
a dream team ma'am shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we
king james
welcome to the space jam
you gotta win this game let's end this
and get our son back
yikes
classic welcome to the space camp
i'm going old school on his butt
[Applause]
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i made mistakes choosing
between what the world wants you to be
i know you are
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world
i'm sorry we had our orders and we
played the aurora it wasn't real
it was real for me
[Music]
[Music]
one thing's for sure
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
on your feet senior chief
john kelly is more dangerous and
effective
than any man we have in the field
[Music]
the only thing he has more than kills
are medals
[Music]
somebody would like to talk to you john
if you're done in there
we need you to get back in the field
senior chief kelly it appears you have a
common enemy with the united states
they took everything from me
my family i got nothing left
their plan is a series of strategic
attacks all over the world
we have to respond i need to be on that
team lieutenant commander greer
you'll lead the mission i'm leaving out
the playing field cia doesn't support
any further investigation into your
wife's murder
battlefield he had no right to take so
much from me
this
they know exactly where we've been
[Music]
now
no remorse
[Music]
this package just came in
[Music]
get everybody out here
[Music]
play me
[Music]
hello detective banks do you know where
your officers are
jigsaw thought that jigsaw killer was
dead
he is
find him there hours not days how can i
catch this guy
if there's nobody on the bus i can fuss
you can't do this alone
whoever did this has another motive
something personal
was the last time you saw your father
jigsaw copycat this is gonna go sideways
fast
all available units officer down that
was just a diversion
to get us out of the precinct
i need everyone on this case
he could be anywhere he could be anyone
we're gonna tear this city apart
[Music]
hello detective banks when was the last
time
you saw your father
let it
the begin humans must be here somewhere
wait
they're coming
is that a burnt orange 1993 station
wagon or is it ah
who are these unstoppable warriors we're
the mitchells the only people who can
save the world
i'm super sorry everyone let me
introduce myself
i'm katie i'm sort of a weirdo my
parents haven't figured me out yet to be
fair
it took me a while to figure myself out
my brother also weird hi would you like
to talk to me about dinosaurs
no okay thank you and my mom katie
faceguy
all of us really how about we put our
phones down and we can make 10 seconds
of unobstructed family eye contact
starting now
see this is good right here this is
natural
every family has its challenges we
haven't had a good family picture in
years because you two are always arguing
for my family our greatest challenge
probably the robot apocalypse
all robots capture every single person
on the planet
yeah what would a functional family do
butterfly formation
so we just do that right
who's behind this how i gave you all
boundless knowledge and you've
put your family on three right now
sorry all right
i'll find them now everything with a
computer chip is alive
mitchells have always been weird and
that's what makes us great
hold on a second what's the furby
[Music]
me
strawberry red velvet
blue velvet
[Music]
wow
how about the pickups i hear there's a
problem
i'm the former police commissioner as a
woman
you're a caretaker hey damon
you do what i'm telling you to do and
everything will be just fine
i need you tonight using some of your
old skills
five stops five pickups
i will find you don't you
cry she took out his crew
right under your crooked cop nose i need
to know right now
are you in or out
let's do this
you got three more stops i need to get
my daughter back
and it is not safe for me out there i
don't see that you have
much choice tommy's not your friend
[Music]
three more stops two more stops
one more stop
get rid of that for me
let me give you some advice you can't
care about anyone else
everyone else is an obstacle
you care what an obstacle wants or feels
you're dead
if i'd cared about anyone or thing i
might have died
you have the talent whether you have the
killer
instinct is the big question
she thought she owned everyone that's
foolish unhinged
well you're fired why are you speaking i
think you mixed me
but there's something about poetic
justice that's just so
poetic you won't admit
[Music]
this doesn't have to be a scene it
really really does
i'd like to remind you all that i'm
doing this in heels
what was your name crueler
you have a bit of an extreme side yes
darling
what fun that is
she stole my dogs
i guess you must hate her she has made
it me or her
and i choose me
don't worry there's lots more bad things
coming perhaps
perhaps
who am i
what do you want to do in your life
frankie i don't know all right what kind
of stuff you want to make
i think you got potential i want to make
your next picture really yeah
what now yeah right now yo what's up
thanks for checking out this video
my little niece worships these guys who
do and say nothing
yo why is my existence so lit and
promote a lifestyle doing and saying
nothing
hashtag swimming pool that's that
cocktail i think this pineapple life
you can't be following me like i'm no
one special man
you've got talent do you want to be the
guys that made two cool videos
do you want to be no one special
this is the beginning people came
oh my god we're all here
it's crazy how good this is huh
we have phone or no phone i'm charles
melton and i'm here with no one special
then we have a game show bad idea
good idea i love you no one's special
this is just feeling so right
we're about to go stratospheric
you know i see you right you see me
don't hurt her
i love that jake
[Music]
are you prepared let the world see the
real you
he's not who he says he is your success
directly contradicts your message
doesn't know you tell
viewers they're stupid they're watching
us i want you to wake up because you're
getting swept up
you're so jealous of him get the viewers
back up before we lose anymore
a prophet will not be accepted in his
hometown you get to lead the revolution
it could be really powerful
if you told me one single thing that was
true
hey myself
[Music]
i'm no one special cut
that was great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
birthday trip to hawaii come on birthday
girl we actually have
another surprise for you which on
someone willing to take us to the island
how else are you going to finish this
book it was supposed to be a surprise
[Music]
surprise
do not miss that trip home
the first people to set foot on that
island since its forced
shutdown what happened here again dozens
of unexplained disappearances
and the locals swear by the existence of
the half-faced girl
so much for hawaii's scariest resort no
ghosts
all stories they're not just gonna be on
display sam
we should probably go home we have a
little bit of time the weather
is getting really weird this doesn't
feel right
are you sure this is where we came here
[Music]
someone's here who's that
[Music]
it's not a luncheon
[Music]
[Music]
i'm the owner of a salvage business and
i have a job over
i want you to help me break into the
most secure vault in the world
okay very good do you know who
francis drake was he stole the spanish
treasure and that's
what's in the bag i'm told wealth you
probably need a safe cracker i'm an
engineer i need your mind
or others to see an impossible task you
might see a solution
the war room meet the team a computer
wins
acquisition planning and extraction
he's gonna mastermind the infiltration
the vault what it is how it works
we can't work it out no one has and if
we get caught
we're going down for a very long time
are you sure you're prepared for that
are you kids got bald
the bank of spain the most impenetrable
building on the planet across the street
the headquarters of the spanish army on
alert for any attempts on the bank
when spain plays its world cup games
every camera will be pointing away from
the building
which gives us 105 minutes to get the
job done
simple stage one vault
keys
he's a college kid you're putting our
lives in his hands
no problem just stay until the job
you're good
they say my mother was one of the
greatest to ever rise
stay wild and even though she's been
gone since i was a baby
no
[Music]
there are still moments where i can feel
her spirit
[Music]
did you ever see my mom perform oh yes
she was a legend
hola you look just like your mother
you must be lucky prescott i like your
dress oh and your shoes i didn't know
shoes could be
cute horses can do that
is that barn okay
this horse got a lot of spirit you do
have a lot of spirit
easy boy
let's go girl good thing your name's
lucky well is her middle name irony
i just rode a horse around here we call
that hanging on for dear life
you are lucky you didn't get yourself
killed you stay away from that horse
that is not his fault
i'm trying to keep you safe he said
let's get out of this town
just take it slow horses can feel what
you feel
it's in your heart to run free it's in
mine too
i'm gonna call you spirit
let's round up that hurt boys we need to
get spirit back to his family this is a
terrible idea
sign me up
i believe in you lucky you have your
mother's spirit
[Music]
stay wild
[Music]
[Music]
we'll need the strength of a thousand
[Music]
marshmallows
[Music]
my husband took the boat out on the lake
he took a handgun that i didn't even
know that we owned and
[Music]
did he leave a note he did
you were right there is
nothing nothing is after you
you're safe now
you said you were safe safe from one
[Music]
[Music]
you know that we're paying people to do
that right you don't have to do it all
yourself
owen
i didn't think we had secrets everybody
has secrets
it's our house but backwards
what the hell was he doing
you were right you were right
there is nothing
you're safe now
happy homecoming to our kappa newbies
[Applause]
boys it's real simple top comment an
exclamation point
tag the hoes to protect the bros
something's happened with your brother
we just
found him at his fraternity we have one
victim
and are still looking for a suspect
please call us if you have any
information
we've had issues of cyber bullying on
campus
what do they post an exclamation point
if someone's in here
last year that girl
something happened to her
this is something that if it were to
spiral out of control
it could hurt all of us
i'm hoping to keep this between us
i
[Music]
you